these are the three best Tim Dylan rants
from 2023 starting off with World War II
World War III will be the most
entertaining thing before you are emoli
in your house by a Chinese nuke you will
not have to do anything you will be
looking at your treadmill on your couch
when you're vaporized no one will come
to you and ask you to do anything except
maybe you go to the call center coming
in at number two is the corporate office
rant from episode 371 fight for the
office WI we're going back we're going
back we're go where's that energy it's
all for Israel and the Palestine where's
the energy to go back into the office to
crawl back into it crawl into it we're
going back and at number one is Tim
Dylan on Kamala Harris Kamala Harris
cannot say a sentence she talks in like
Gypsy
curses when they ask her something